>> ERIC: Hi, I’m Eric. As you can tell,
I’m an avid cyclist but I’m also the lead
product manager for Google products on the
world’s first Android phone, the T-Mobile
G1. I’m here to tell you about the Google
goodies that come pre-loaded on this phone.
There's search, maps, YouTube, Gmail, contacts,
calendar, and talk. With an Android phone,
everything is made simple. Once you log in
with a single sign in, all your Google apps
are available and automatically synchronized
with the web. You’ll never have to log in
again. You can still protect all your stuff
by creating a screen lock pattern like these
one. Let’s say you just met a new friend
and you want to add her as a contact. Let
me add Kate, a cyclist I met on my ride last
weekend. I can add Kate’s phone number,
email, address, and more. All Google apps
on Android are fully synchronized so whatever
you do on your phone appears on your computer
and vice versa. So when I save Kate’s info
on the phone, in a matter of seconds, it will
appear on the web. This also means that all
of Kate’s info is safe and always available.
So even if you lose or break your phone, there’s
no need to panic because you’re always synched
to your Google account. So after I log in
and unlock my new Android phone, all my information
is safe and immediately available. See? Kate’s
info is still there. This is true for more
than just your contacts, your calendar events,
emails, IM chats are all synched between the
phone and the web. If I create an event on
my computer like my bike ride with Kate this
afternoon, shortly after, it will appear on
my phone. There. I just got a notification
on my status bar. The status bar is where
I get notified of new emails, new IM messages,
calendar events, text messages, and so on.
In a single swipe, you get an update on everything
without the need to check each and every one
individually. Oh, here. Kate’s just confirmed
our bike ride plans. To answer Kate, I’ve
got many options and you can find them all
on the contacts app. I can text; IM, email
and, of course, call. I’ll reply with Google
Talk. One last cool thing about Google apps
on Android, with just a couple of clicks,
you can get a map of your contact's address.
Now, Kate said we should meet near the second
cement anchor on the Golden Gate Bridge. I’m
not exactly sure what that is so I’ll use
Street View to find the exact location. Ah,
that’s where it is. Time to hit the road.
To learn more about the Google mobile products
on the world’s first Android phone, the
T-Mobile G1, visit mobile.google.com/android.